I'm upset progressives let's call him
regressives samir entrepreneurs and the
regressives are winning the battle for
hearts and minds
thousands of Amazon employees are forced
to rely on food stamps Medicaid in
public housing Berni complaints and the
media joked to agree richest guy in the
world and he's got employees on food
stamps the left-wing media of course and
the right to a huge number of Amazon
workers are so poorly paid they qualify
for federal welfare benefits at first
Bezos fought back Amazon calling the
claims quote inaccurate misleading at
that point I was cheering pay zones for
standing up for capitalism and the Sun
Prime helps members I already liked them
because of the service he created I buy
all kinds of stuff right from my couch
the goods arrive quickly and they're
comparatively cheap in fact Amazon's
reduced prices so much but it may have
lowered the inflation rate hurray for
Amazon stand-up is how we start every
single shift it's not company's fault
that some workers qualify for handouts
more people would collect them if Amazon
we're not hiring by creating jobs
Bezos gives workers better choices but
the media don't report that they make
working for Amazon look like oppression
it's described as a cutthroat corporate
jungle where workers are pitted against
one another 80-hour workweeks are the
norm so Amazon caved Amazon is raising
the minimum wage for all of its workers
the anchors smile but the raise comes
with a cost yes the higher minimum is
good for these workers who have jobs now
but beginners people like Kelsey Holder
will be shut out
[Music]
minimum wages I'm kelcie started working
at this restaurant when she was just a
teenager by the time we met her she was
making $20 an hour now she's the
restaurants manager she would have never
had this opportunity had the higher
minimum wage existed when she was higher
because teenagers aren't worth the risk
we quit hiring people without experience
Murph crest who runs this restaurant
says when his state raised its minimum
wage he stopped training newcomers
minimum wage jobs are an entry-level job
to get someone some experience to do
something you raise that high and if you
cut those people out of the market
completely then people stay unemployed
play video games hang out on the street
they never learned to smile at a
customer get to work on time never learn
the job skills that lead to better jobs
later but progressives claim a higher
minimum lifts everyone start out with a
minimum wage that provides basic decent
standard how much is that fifteen bucks
an hour 20 bucks an hour and if you
think that's too high try living on it
by the way I think that would take away
jobs from entry-level people they
wouldn't even get a first job but now
John that is exactly the argument that
people back in the day made against the
minimum wage at least Amazon is just one
company entry-level workers can find
jobs elsewhere but then I learned Jeff
Bezos is company also plans to lobby
Washington to hike the federal minimum
wage now Amazon will try to get
government to force its competition to
pay what amazon pays that's why I'm
upset
Jeff Bezos this entrepreneur I admired
turns out to be just another craven
opportunist
after all Amazon's already replacing
workers with robots basil's knows a
higher minimum wage will hurt his
competitors more than it hurts him
clever use government to handcuff your
rivals and then pat yourself on the back
and pander to people who promise free
stuff there is absolutely now no reason
why other profitable corporations like
Walmart why they also should not be
paying their employees at least $15 an
hour after all those companies make
billions say progressives partly thanks
to indefensible exploitation of
hard-working decent Americans how are
they exploited they're not forced to
work there they have other choices they
pick that job oh it was your best they
could get maybe it was because all the
others were even worse maybe but isn't
there some point at which the results of
this remarket just shock the conscience
of decent people yes there are gross
parts to capitalism greed gaudy excess
and great inequality but when
self-interested business owners are left
free to make their own decisions about
whom they hire and what they pay more
people benefit especially poor people I
wish I could give more kids job if there
were lower minimum wage I could hire
maybe two or three more I shouldn't be
surprised that Bezos uses government to
get special favors he's done that before
a bill authorizing billions of dollars
in tax incentives Amazon didn't just
announce the second headquarters it
started a competition to see which
politicians would squeeze their tax
payers most Stonecrest Georgia wants
Amazon to build its second headquarters
there so badly that the City Council
voted that if chosen they will D annex a
portion of the city and rename it Amazon
give me a break politicians shouldn't
pander to companies and companies
shouldn't pander to politicians
I wish Bezos would stick to innovative
not scheming with government to get
special advantage some of the worst and
mieze of capitalism are capitalists